ja hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück
auf meinem kanal wie schön dass ihr
wieder mit dabei seit heute machen wir
mal eine gartentour es ist jetzt bald
april also zeige ich euch mal was gerade
in unserem selbstversorger garten alles
wächst und wie ihr euer eigenes gemüse
anbauen können falls ihr mich noch nicht
kennt ich bin marie ich war das obst und
gemüse für meine familie fast komplett
selber an und auf diesem kanal hier da
zeige ich euch jedes geht
[Musik]
seht ihr die kerle da oben auf dem dach
sind die frauen unserer nachbarn die
haben jetzt schon entschieden auf einem
dreistöckigen haus über nach diesen
einfach hoch geflogen
ich hoffe sehr dass sie sich nicht allzu
sehr von den gemüsegarten interessieren
weil ich glaube dass ich sie davon
abhalten können ich noch meine beete zu
plündern wenn sie das unbedingt rollen
in dem beet hier hinter mir wachsen
weißkohl und feldsalat den weißkohl habe
ich ziemlich spät letztes jahr gepflanzt
eigentlich ein bisschen zu spät ich hab
noch ziemlich spät im jahr quäntchen
bekommen auch den jungpflanzen und
dachte ach komm eine kleine ernte wird
es schon geben damit kann man noch mal
einen kleinen flecken im garten füllen
der sonst leer stehen würde und das hat
wirklich geklappt ich glaube ich hab dir
erst im september gepflanzt die haben
hier im b team überwintert und jetzt
sind die köpfe zwar nicht riesig aber
wir haben eine ganz frühe weißkohl
während es ist jetzt auch sinnvoll die
nach und nach zu ihren weil die im
zweiten jahr ja anfangen zu blühen ist
und zweijährige pflanzen und die würden
jetzt anfangen samenstände auszubilden
demnächst deswegen sehen wir zu dass wir
die vorher alle aufessen der feldsalat
es gerade noch ein bisschen eingefroren
deswegen warte ich noch einen moment
bevor ich den ernte weil wenn man
eingefrorenen pflanzen erntet dann
trauen die zu hause auf und sind
matschig aber wenn man die im beet
auftauen lässt also die lebendige
pflanze auftauen lässt dann bei dem
ganzen winterharten pflanzen wachsen die
einfach weiter sind wieder frisch und
knackig und dann kann man die ernten und
sie sind genauso wie man es gewohnt ist
zu hause wenn man sie dann essen möchte
es ist ein bisschen so wie wenn man
tiefkühl spinat auftaucht dann ist er ja
auch ziemlich matschig und nicht mehr so
frisch und knackig wenn die pflanzen
eingefroren sind dann sollte man die
auch gar nicht anfassen weil die dadurch
schaden nehmen können und die komplett
in ruhe lassen auch nicht
unkraut hier hätten dann zwischen den
pflanzen oder sonst irgendwas war dass
wir den wirklich eher schaden als nutzen
[Musik]
in diesem beet dahinten wachsen vor
allem blumen und kräuter klappt eben
lange zeit keinen einzigen flecken in
meinem garten tulln gelassen weil ich
unbedingt so viel essen wie möglich
selber anbauen wollte es gibt aber auch
blumen die man essen kann und selbst die
die man nicht essen kann gehört neben
die einfach in den garten dazu oder wie
seht ihr das auf jeden fall kann man an
diesem beet was ganz spannendes sehen
und zwar lege ich meine bta mit pappe
und kompost an wie das genau
funktioniert zeige ich euch in meinem
mini kurs das gemüsegarten boot camp ist
kostenlos könnt ihr euch gerne für
anmelden ich kann euch den link nochmal
in die video beschreibung packen da habe
ich im ersten video die komplette
anleitung wie man diese beete anlegt und
wenn ihr das schon gesehen habe dann
wisst ihr dass man dafür gebraucht und
einige leute fragen immer kann man die
pappe weglassen natürlich die kann man
auf jeden fall weg lassen das hat nur
den unterschied dass das unkraut
durchkommt sie verwenden diese beet
anlegen technik eben weil da kein
unkraut mehr in den beeten wächst oder
kaum noch unkraut und an der stelle hat
uns die pappe gefehlt also da ist uns
die sache ausgegangen
wir haben dieses bild ohne papa angelegt
und man merkt einen enormen unterschied
also in dem beet jährlich ungefähr
genauso oft wie in meinem ganzen
restlichen garten so viel gras und
unkraut kommt da immer noch durch das
ist also der unterschied es funktioniert
auch ohne aber damit muss man eben leben
das man dann dafür mehr unkraut in
seinen bieten hat ich kann euch gerne
noch mal ein video verlinken indem ich
euch genau erzählen wie man das
hinkriegt dass man unkrautfrei gärtner
das weil ich euch gerne mal da oben oder
ist es hier um ja darum so ganz genau
wie ich mir das immer noch nicht gemerkt
[Musik]
daneben stehen unsere winter zwiebeln
die haben wir im herbst gesteckt das ist
eine sorte die überwintert auf dem weg
hierhin schon einen wachstumsvorsprung
hat jetzt im frühling können wir jetzt
schon als frühlingszwiebeln ernten wir
können dabei auch noch warten ungefähr
im juli sind die dann erntereif genauso
wie andere küchen zwiebeln auch das ist
eine ganz tolle sache das mache ich auch
jedes jahr und jetzt im frühling ist die
zeit wo man zwischen den winter zwiebeln
die möhren aussehen kann das ist eine
ganz tolle mit kultur möhren und
zwiebeln und das werde ich auf jeden
fall machen im moment ist es noch sehr
sehr kalt es ist für mehrere tage frost
angekündigt deswegen rate ich noch mit
ihren aussagen
das ist immer ganz klug wenn man da so
ein bisschen den wetterbericht im blick
hat so dass man die samen nicht
unbedingt dann in die erde jetzt bin ich
gerade ganz ganz ganz kalt es draußen
dann kommt unser rettig das wird jetzt
auch abgeerntet weil ich sorge habe dass
die anfangen zu blühen
daraus werde ich ein schönes sauerkraut
machen ein rettig sauerkraut man kann ja
alle möglichen gemüse fermentieren und
ich denke dass es sehr lecker sein wird
also in kim chi habe ich schon oft
verwendet und sind ihnen da super gut
ich habe einen gärtner gerade frei
geworden ist also werden wir nachher
noch und sein kleines rettig sauerkraut
ansetzen
ja und hier wachsen meine dicken bohnen
die sind auch gerade noch etwas
eingefroren die listen sich dann wieder
auf wenn es wärmer wird den nachtfrost
auch gar nichts aus so wie allen gemüsen
die ich euch jetzt hier zeige in dieser
gartentour die haben alle den ganzen
winter überstanden auf den beeten dicke
bohnen haben einen feind nämlich die
schwarze bodenlos die werden davon ganz
stark und ganz oft befallen und ich habe
die beobachtung gemacht dass wenn man
die dicken bohnen im spätsommer aus seht
also mit filmen august dann in den
beeten überwintern lässt dass die dicke
bohnen las ich dann eher von den
pflanzen verhält also dass sie dann
widerstandsfähiger gegen die preise sind
deswegen lasse ich die immer überwintern
man könnte die auch im frühling erst
sehen aber so haben wir auch schon einen
wachstumsvorsprung und können dann
hoffentlich bald kein spiele die combo
und produziert als und auf jeden fall
schon ganz viele blüten dran und ich
freue mich schon das ist somit eine der
ersten ernten die man dann im frühling
von den neuen genießen ernten kann seht
ihr diesen tollen baum hinter mir
wunderschön aber leider ein kleines
problem für unser gemüse das ist nämlich
eine walnuss und walnüsse sonnen stoffe
ab die anderen pflanzen unter dritten im
wachse weil die alle nährstoffe und das
ganze wasser für sich haben wollen nicht
unterlegen mussten die walnüsse und wir
merken das sehr stark an unseren beten
die sind hier direkt an der walnuss also
hier ist unser gemüsegarten und genau
daneben wächst die walnuss und gerade
die beete die direkt an der walnuss dran
liegen da mehr über das das gemüse sehr
sehr sehr schlecht wächst deswegen haben
wir da zwei hochbeete hingestellt aber
die anderen beiden beete die auch hier
direkt beim sind dann merkt man dass
auch richtig richtig stark also diesen
einfluss von der walnuss ich habe zum
beispiel letztes jahr hier rote beete
gesät und die hat immer noch keine
knollen ausgebildet dabei wächst rote
beete eigentlich normalerweise ohne viel
zu tun und ich bin echt ein bisschen
ratlos aber ich jetzt hier nochmal
hochbeete hinstellen soll irgendwie habe
ich da eigentlich keine lust brauche ich
finde es irgendwie netter ebenerdig zu
gärtnern weil man dann weniger gießen
muss weil man nicht den aufwand hat dass
man hochbeete bauen muss ihr könnt mir
gerne mal schreiben wenn ihr
irgendwelche vorschläge hat aber es
bereitet mir schon ein bisschen kummer
weil es in dem einen jahr zwei große
beete die und so verloren gehen oder auf
denen wir quasi kein gemüse anbauen
können weil es einfach nicht wachsen
will in den hochbeeten selber da wächst
alles gut da ist ja die erde
ausgetauscht so dass die pflanzen gar
nicht mit der mutter wurden in kontakt
kommen der durch die walnuss verpasste
wurde aber da so der große unterschied
dass ich ja in meinem garten möglichst
wenig gießen will und ich bin es nicht
so ganz gewohnt dass durch die hochbeete
trotzdem ließe war in den hochbeeten
verdunstet ganz viel wasser die wir
einen super schnell trockene und das ist
so mein kleiner kampf mit den hochbeeten
dass sich dahinter her sein muss mit dem
ließen und daran denken muss ist genauso
wie im gewächshaus da muss ich mich auch
immer dreimal genannt weil das schließen
einfach normalerweise nicht auf meiner
to do liste steht deswegen sind unsere
ebenerdigen beete auf jeden fall
ertragreicher als die hochbeete aber hey
ich mich einfach mal am riemen reißen
dann werden die auch richtig gute
ergebnisse produzieren ich muss einfach
nur an das blöde ist nicht englisch ja
die hochbeete sind
größtenteils abgeerntet daten wie spinat
drin und einige andere gemüse und die
haben willst aufgefüllt mit neuem
kompost und da kennen wir jetzt wenn der
frost vorbei ist die neuen gemüse
einsehen der asia salat den sie hier in
den hochbeeten haben der letzten super
super meat absolute anbau tipp wenn ihr
auf asyl salat steht das ist eine tolle
möglichkeit um im winter immer noch ganz
viel grünzeug aus dem eigenen garten zu
essen da kann man nicht sehen kann man
regelmäßig extrem cars abwerten und es
wächst immer wieder nach und lässt sich
nicht beirren auch in kalten
temperaturen einfach weiter zu wachsen
ja hier ist das zweite weg ist auch so
von der balance beeinträchtigt ist hier
wächst und so winter salat die leute ist
baghlan mir einige von euch jetzt auch
schon eingebaut nachdem ich die
eigentlich in jedem video wo sich das
anbietet in wien an preise das ist eine
ganz tolle salat sollte die man den
ganzen winter über ernten kann leider
wächst der aufgrund der walnuss nicht so
super dieses jahr aber immerhin so dass
wir immer noch genug eigenen salat
ernten können was ich jetzt mache ist
dass ich wenn es jetzt wirklich kalt
wird jetzt noch mal richtig starke
minusgrade geben dann werde ich denen
mit einem vlies abdecken
ich habe da diese bogen stangen sind
aufgebaut und da kann ich jetzt auch ein
gärtner fließt über packen um den salat
ein bisschen ein zu murmeln damit der
uns nicht matschig kreiert aber
normalerweise über steht ja auch starke
- gerade wunderbar dann kommen die 3
beta auf denen wir uns ein winter kohl
hatten wir hatten da vor allem wirsing
und rosenkohl und auch ein bisschen
sellerie noch mittags zwischen der ist
ja auch relativ rosstat und die haben
wir jetzt allesamt abgeerntet ein
wilsing steht noch da 92 ja weil die
jetzt anfangen zu blühen also wenn du
rosenkohl und wir singen doch in deinem
beten hast dann fang mal an den auf zu
essen weil er fängt jetzt an zu schießen
der wir jetzt eine rosenkohl babys und
wirsing babys machen und dann ist es gut
wenn man den vorher auf ist weiter lang
nicht mehr so lecker schmeckt wenn ihr
einmal angefangen hat zu gehen
die beete sind jetzt frei für die
nächsten aussaaten ich wäre da ein paar
zwiebeln stecken und dann später paprika
und auberginen
bauen die haben noch ein bisschen zeit
die können ja jetzt noch nicht in den
garten alle wärmeliebenden pflanzen
müssen bis mitte mai warten bis man die
in den garten auspflanzen kann aber ich
glaube sie eben vorher schon mal ein
paar schnell wachsende hre kleine gemüse
so dass wir dann die paprika dazwischen
pflanzen können und bis die paprika den
ganzen platz braucht werden sie dann die
trauben schon abgeerntet haben und so
können wir das beta noch mehr nutzen
weil jetzt steht es leer und es wäre
einfach schade den ganzen platz bis
mitte mai jetzt nicht nutzen zu können
da hinten hat mein sohn sein bild dass
es immer das schönste bild im ganzen
garten weil der sich nicht zu schade ist
für pflanzen und da immer ganz viel blut
in seinem bt hat auch ganz viele
erdbeeren gepflanzt letztes jahr und
knoblauch und die wachsen auch schon
richtig gut dann eben ist ein beta ist
gerade frei geworden ist da haben wir
jetzt schon die nächste charge bakir
salat gepflanzt und da werden wir jetzt
auch rote beete sehen dann kommen
stangenbohnen noch dazu das ist eine
tolle mischkultur rote beete und
stangenbohnen und ich liebe das auch so
stangenbohnen anzubauen mit so einem
schönen gerüst ist einfach super hübsch
oder die haben auch so schöne blüten
gerade so feuer boden da freue ich mich
auf jeden fall schon wenn die endlich in
die erde kommen an der stelle wo die
stangen boden hinkommen sollen wächst
jetzt noch der backe salat das ist
wieder so eine abfolge so dass wir das
beet jetzt schon nutzen können und dann
wenn die starken boden gesetzt werden
können was auch erst später im jahr ist
dann ist der parcours salat schon so
groß dass man den ernten kann bevor die
stangenbohnen den platz komplett
brauchen es ist ein paar sinnvoll sich
zu überlegen welche gemüse den platz im
bett wie lange beanspruchen so dass man
eben diese zwischen pflanzung machen
kann so dass man es genau takten kann
dass die beete das ganze jahr über
genutzt sind wenn ihr keine lust habt
euch den kopf zu zerbrechen oder ein
bisschen inspiration wollt wie ich das
mache dann ladet euch gerne meinen
garten plan herunter der es auch
kostenlos die linke ich euch auch in die
video beschreibung habt ihr einen
fertigen plan wo ihr gar nicht mehr
nachdenken muss sondern einfach
rausgehen könnt und anfangen könnt euer
gemüse selber ein super und dann gibt es
natürlich noch das gewächshaus starten
wir jetzt auch stehen gemüse drin da
waren die hühner zwischenzeitlich im
winter mal drin
wir haben paar wochen gelegt die im
boden fühlen mit ihrem dünger
angereichert und da den boden
vorbereitet dann haben wir noch kompost
ausgebracht damit haben wir hier auch
noch ein neues beet angelegt da bin ich
schon sehr gespannt was sich da rein zu
lassen will dass es nämlich immer im
jetzigen garten war noch gar nicht
berücksichtigt ich bin gerade stark für
kräuter aber wer weiß was mir da noch
einfällt es gibt immer was was man
pflanzen kann und in das gewächshaus
kommen dann demnächst im ende april je
nachdem wie das wetter wird die tomaten
paprika wir wollen auch eine
wassermelone im gewächshaus an waren da
freue ich mich auch schon darauf
hoffentlich wird das was ja schon
wassermelonen im freiland die haben
schon eine ernte abgeworfen aber die
früchte sind sehr klein geblieben also
schauen wir mal wie das mit der
gewächshaus wassermelone dieses jahr
laufen wird ein paar erdnüsse werde ich
ins gewächshaus pflanzen die entwickeln
sich übrigens prächtig das passende
video kann ich euch hier oben verlinkten
ich werde dieses jahr erdnüsse anbauen
und das mal ausprobieren ob die wirklich
in deutschland wachsen
ein paar will ich ins freiland pflanzen
den fans zu sechst aus damit wir das
besser vergleichen können
und du bisher wachsen im gewächshaus
zwiebeln spinat und mangold das sind
alles kulturen die relativ schnell
wachsen die zwiebeln wollen wir nur für
frühlings triebe in anbauen so dass der
platz dann wenn die tomaten und die
paprika einziehen nun größtenteils von
denen genutzt werden kann weil das ich
wichtiger ist dass wir möglichst viel
platz für haben weil wir super viele
tomaten anbauen möchten
das ist der spinat schön an land hier
sind überall zwiebeln gesteckt ein paar
jungpflanzen dahin
und ein kleiner wackler natürlich wie
sollte es anders sein in der wohnung wo
wir vorher gewohnt haben da wächst sogar
immer noch baku in den fugen der aufwand
habe ich letztens gesehen ich weiß nicht
wie der da hingekommen ist aber wir
hinterlassen unsere spuren ich habe alle
kulturen die jetzt im gewächshaus
wachsen an den rand gesät und gepflanzt
so dass ich die tomaten schon ins
gewächshaus pflanzen kann
während diese gemüse noch drin stehen
und die möglichst wenig platz einnehmen
und die tomaten schon mal anfangen
können ist zu wachsen und sobald die
tomaten an größer sind und die paprika
und was auch immer da alles noch
gepflanzt wird sind der spinalen der
mangold und auch die zwiebeln
hoffentlich schon alle aufgegessen
dieser garten hier den haben wir vor
allem für das feine gemüse also für die
kulturen die mehr aufmerksamkeit
brauchen das ganze acker gemüse wächst
bei uns in einem anderen garten da kann
ich euch auch noch mal eine tour geben
wenn wir da alles vorbereitet haben oder
ob ich auch zeigen wie wir alles
vorbereiten
da wachsen kartoffeln kürbis mais noch
mehr zwiebeln viel mehr zwiebeln new
york pastinaken und so diese ganzen
gemüse die auch ohne die aufmerksamkeit
ganz gut weiter wachsen und von denen
man richtig große mengen braucht wenn
man sich selber versorgen möchte das ist
also unser acker und hier haben wir das
ganze gemüse dass man auch regelmäßig
geerntet und das ein bisschen mehr
pflege und aufmerksamkeit braucht weil
der ak ziemlich weit entfernt liegt da
müssen wir dann immer mit dem auto
hinfahren und das machen wir nur alle
paar wochen
[Musik]
ich bin gerade dabei das sauerkraut zu
machen aus dem schwarzen hätte ich vor
gott ist es ja eigentlich gar nicht aber
ich fände das nach dem gleichen prinzip
ich kann euch gerne mal eine anleitung
zum gemüse fermentieren und ein
individuum beschreibung packen da habe
ich jede menge tolle informationen auf
meinem blog
ich bin sehr gespannt wie es am ende
schmecken wird so die erfahrung habe ich
das noch nicht ausprobiert und ja ich
war ganz ehrlich gerade im gesicht also
nicht wenn ich nebenbei ein bisschen
chance weil ich einfach super gerne ich
hab so norman weiß nicht ob er das lied
kennen das heißt scarlett paintings und
irgendwie ihr euch das rauf und runter
jeden fall
[Musik]
da drüben habe ich euch ein video
verlinkt indem ich euch zeige wie wir es
schaffen unser gemüse und unser obst und
drei stunden pro woche komplett selber
anzubauen
da unten findet ihr auch noch ein
spannendes video ich freue mich wenn wir
uns gleich da oder da wiedersehen hat
noch einen wunderschönen tag systems